I told SiriusXM the company we work for
Sirius XM Pandora that I would go out to
California to inaugurate their new
Studios they want me out there and and
you know we're gonna do some interesting
shows they're already been planning him
then what was the weird thing I heard
about Brent I think Brent's gonna go to
LA I don't understand Brent's marriage I
mean I'm not gonna it's weird he's
supposedly if he goes to LA he has
permission to [ __ ] girls in LA without
his wife hair he doesn't even have to
have permission it's an open well I
think half he it's just when he gets
home he has to tell her about she's
getting closer and closer
open marriage yeah I don't know I don't
know marriage Brent what's the deal when
you go to LA real quick you're able to
[ __ ] whoever you want LA correct and you
I think like let's say we're somewhere
and woman's to say Brent I gotta have
you you have to quickly call your wife
or he just [ __ ] her and then tell her
about it when you get home I've got pre
permission to [ __ ] her and tell her when
we when I get home Wow I have to tell
every detail how did we know you're
gonna remember every detail well I've
got a 122 working memory and by the way
she similarly while you're in LA she can
[ __ ] whoever she wants correct here Wow
yes dude what is gone hey hey listen
whatever III hope it works out come up
did she bring it up well she she brought
it up before like if I go on the road
right um I can or two do anything she
was like you have pre permission to have
sex well that'll bother you on some
level not at all like like hey but
should my wife not want that you know
like man should be a little jealous can
this resemble a marriage in some way
yeah I mean we're best friends right
well it's just when it comes to sex
anything goes yeah when it comes to sex
it's a completely separate thing Julie
was telling me his theory is you will
not get laid in LA and Kaitlyn's gonna
[ __ ] like 15 he's going around by saying
that to everyone now you might as well
know what he's saying what else is he
gonna say he also said that we weren't
gonna swing either yeah
true it was wrong about that right had
wrong as per the usual but he thinks he
forced you into swinging thank him he
can't he can't force anybody into
anything right truly your theory is
Brent will not get any action in LA he's
not close he's got a better shot at
closing a three-picture action movie
deal in that way they get laid out there
now I'm gonna watch the whole I'm gonna
I'm gonna be on you I'm gonna be
monitoring him when you go out to get
laid
I'm coming with you Wow I want to see
this once and for all your assignment is
to trail Brent no matter what and I'm
with that not to get in the way come on
you can't throw salt in my game buddy
I'm rooting for you I hope you can say
you'll help him from him I don't I just
want him to keep his distance I don't
want people to know that we're even
there together alright fair enough all
right fair enough
and also Howard I'd like to request that
we have the same room - oh sure yes No
thank you so you can't sneak out on I
want to see Brent in action outside of
here I don't need a lot of time to hang
with Brandon if you're gonna observe him
in his natural habitat got him rumors
right bring the girl
well you can have separate bedrooms he
needs to be right next to in fact you
need to share a bed I need some time
away from this I cannot I mean I'm
around him all day I heard your plan is
to go to the Rainbow Room to pick up
girls you have actual plan yeah I'd love
that's where I'm comfortable that's
where I would hang out when I lived in
LA and I'm cute I want to see what's his
outfit like when he goes to the rainbow
probably to show off his tattoos close a
deal like which metal shirt is he
wearing are there any pins I have a lot
of questions right all right well yeah
we're gonna put you guys in a room
together oh please I need some time away
we just ruined the trip Ellie
all right boys while we look forward to
the LA trip and hereby curse off
swinging and full-on swinging news
Capades we want to know it all and Brent
will be swingin in LA